[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué fuerza mueve un grupo de personas a
trabajar por más de 20 horas sin comer
sin dormir sin ni siquiera tomar bien
agua
quien le paga a un voluntario
que recibe a cambio
el 19 de septiembre de 2017 yo estaba en
un piso 25 de la ciudad de mexico
estaba sentada y la mesa empezó a
brincar no a bailar como en otras
ocasiones
creo que lo que se nos vino a la mente a
todos fue en 1985 mismo día
nos levantamos como resortes empezamos a
caminar por los pasillos dando tumbos
para replegarlos al centro de las
oficinas
tembló una eternidad
en lo que estábamos esperando la orden
de evacuación del edificio
mandando mensajes temblorosos a nuestras
familias tratando
empezamos a ver nubes de polvo en
diferentes direcciones de la ciudad
verdes que se cayeron dijimos no creo
que haya entendiéramos la magnitud de lo
que acababa de suceder
bajamos las escaleras de los 25 pisos en
absoluto silencio
fue cuando empecé a caminar rumbo a mi
casa que vi que la ciudad estaba
colapsada una de las ciudades más
grandes del planeta nosotros éramos un
éxodo extraño de gente aturdida y
confundida los carros estaban
completamente parados había gente arriba
del metrobus todavía esperando como que
alguien les dijera que hacer había gente
afuera de las farmacias pidiendo dinero
para comprar más medicinas y donar
pasaban los paramédicos en ecobici
a la altura de uno de una estáis más
sacar la altura de uno de los edificios
donde murieron más personas unas
oficinas había gente polvosa y golpeada
yo los vi y dije que les habrá pasado
porque seguía sin entender
34 kilómetros más adelante yo estaba
formada en la tiendita de la esquina de
mi casa iba a comprar agua el plan era
encerrarme con mi prima a ver series y
tratar de pasar el susto en lo que
estábamos formados llegó una chica a
pedirnos que si queríamos donar agua
ya que un edificio se había colapsado
dos calles más allá de mi casa
y dijo las tres palabras que me sacaron
de una patada de mi aturdimiento
hay gente atrapada
cuando llegamos al sitio la gente ya
estaba organizada era una fila de un
señor trajeado la chica de tacón es el
de la gasolinera al poli
estaban pasando escombro en baldes y en
botes en lo que habían encontrado
lo depositaban ahí en la banqueta en una
línea que ya le daba vuelta a la cuadra
estuvimos ahí un buen rato
allí aprendimos que cuando los de
adelante levantaban el puño
teníamos que detener lo que estuviéramos
haciendo
guardar absoluto silencio y rezar
varias veces tuvimos la oportunidad de
bajar el brazo para aplaudir
y es que no hay una sensación más
reconfortante que la de escuchar a
alguien gritar está vivo cobijas para
médicos
estos momentos se fueron volviendo cada
vez más escasos
no hubo ninguno el miércoles
el miércoles al final del día estaba
todo muy tranquilo yo estaba en el
centro de acopio ya habían dicho que no
quedaba nadie
habían metido la maquinaria pesada ya
tenía un par de horas trabajando habían
sacado a todos los voluntarios
pero empezaron a oír a alguien
los que estábamos ahí empezamos por
horas a sacar escombro de piedra en
piedra de bote en bote mano cadena
se nos paraba el corazón cada vez que
los de adelante levantaban el puño para
oír para localizar
volvíamos con tanta fuerza cuando lo
bajaban para gritar nos ciudad
y es que están ahí casi debajo de ti
resistiendo seis heridos aterrados
gritando por su vida
tú dejas de pensar
te concentras en la pequeña piedra en la
que zuma en la que le vas quitando a
alguien de encima
decían decían que se detectaba una
persona por la máquina térmica decían
que se oían dos cuando bajaban los
micrófonos decían que era una chica
decían que era un tipo solamente
realmente nunca sabes lo que está
sucediendo y honestamente no tienes por
qué saber eres manos exactamente igual
que el de enfrente que el de enseguida
tratas tratas de obedecer ante ese caos
ordenado y la buena voluntad de los que
se atreven a tomar decisiones en esas
circunstancias
el jueves
a las 7 de la mañana
yo estaba sentada en el piso en el atrio
de uno de los edificios de enseguida del
sitio
había un paramédico y un par de vecinos
el paramédico seguía parado erguido con
el casco bajo el brazo
lloraba de impotencia y sus lágrimas se
le hacían loco en las caras
se apresuraron a meter las máquinas
decía íbamos lentos pero sin riesgos
uno de los que estaba ya atrapado dijo
perdió la vida cuando con maquinaria
pesada trataron de levantar la losa
grande y se quebró
si había una chica dijo la oíamos no
estábamos locos lo que pasa es que no
estaba allí estaba más en la esquina no
escanearon bien
se la llevaron con el escombro
si dijo un vecino la otra paramédico nos
dijo que cuando se la habían entregado
estaba todavía tibia
ya todo había pasado
ese sitio para las actividades de
rescate apenas en jueves
yo no me fui a trabajar
la historia es triste y cruel y no tiene
sentido como todas las tragedias y como
las muchas historias que hubo por toda
la ciudad esos días esas que nos
salieron en la televisión
la impotencia es indescriptible por
momentos crisis que si lo salvas a ellos
dos salvas un poquito de la vida de
todos los que se llevaron
tapados en partes en ambulancias
calladas que te pesan más al niño
llegas a pensar que el que ellos dos
hayan seguido ahí con vida por tanto
tiempo es una señal de que la vida no es
tan corta ni tan vulnerable
durante las tragedias las redes sociales
le ponen a los vídeos ya las fotos un
filtro de cámara y una capa de
brillantina heroica
muy diferente a lo que realmente sucede
en las actividades de rescate
no creo y de verdad no creo que el
sentimiento común allí era el de estar
haciendo algo extraordinario
ni siquiera cuando entraban o salían los
camiones llenos de escombros o la
maquinaria pesada y oíamos los edificios
evacuados dañados en seguida crujir y
los veíamos temblar
ni cuando los soldados mitad frustrados
y mitad asustados nos gritaban sangre y
bola de que no ven que se les
va a caer el edificio encima
ni lo expuesto y vulnerables que
estábamos todos ante la temida réplica
es
no es heroísmo es otra cosa es un
sentimiento muy difícil de plasmar es
estar ahí parado
volteas a ver al de enseguida un
perfecto extraño lo ves a los ojos sin
barreras sin identidades sin egos y
opiniones ni partidos ni posesiones ni
trabajos ni nada de todo eso que te hace
tan individual y único
eso eso lo dejas más allá del cerco que
rodea el sitio todavía más allá de la
fila de personas que esperaban parados
por horas
la oportunidad de ayudar
el privilegio de unirse esa cadena de
eslabones vulnerables
qué es pasar un bote
los siguientes días se escucha por todos
lados y se alaba esa solidaridad
mexicana que nos distingue en tiempos de
desgracia
y la pregunta que queda ahora meses
después es dónde está esa solidaridad en
tiempos de no desgracia
yo seguía hasta hace unas semanas
dándole vueltas y vueltas y vueltas a
esa pregunta en mi cabeza
fui a ver a mi maestro zen
le dije que iba a dar una plática telefe
contando un poquito como de lo que
quería transmitir
me ve y me dice fue lo único que me dijo
me dice
o sea tú quieres hablar de lo que
significa ser humano
pero quieres dar así la plática está
perfecta si me equivoco así como un
héroe
y este pequeño saltamontes vio ahí que
no había entendido nada de lo que me
había tocado vivir que no necesito la
plática perfecta para estar parada aquí
ni dinero de sobra para donar ni todo el
tiempo del mundo para hacer trabajo
voluntario no necesito ser un héroe para
ayudar
para rescatar lo único que necesite
saber era que era humano es decir mortal
muy mortal que esa persona que está ahí
pudo haber sido yo o tú o cualquier
persona
el volcadero de gente que fuimos esos
días me parece que era para encontrar
esa validación de que está bien ser
vulnerables porque lo somos
en tanto podamos conectarnos con los
demás
para mí ahora solidaridad es la
capacidad de ayudar
desde mi jodidez emocional física o
económica
y creo que creo que esos espacios están
abriendo
esos espacios y ahí está la fuerza de la
solidaridad
esta solidaridad que tenemos que ejercer
todos esa identidad nacional
que nos caracterizan solo es que
realmente el ejerzamos todos porque esos
espacios se están abriendo se llaman
fundaciones asociaciones civiles nuevos
movimientos o maneras de organizarnos
entre nosotros 24 o un millón
movimientos como los movimientos
feministas como el mito que precisamente
toma su fuerza a partir de la
vulnerabilidad de género o nuestros
gamers mojados y su vulnerabilidad legal
en eeuu
o cuarenta y tres chicos vulnerables en
la china para que conmovieron a una
nación
espacios válidos apartidistas que me
representen como humanos como civil
donde podamos nuevamente irnos y volcar
esa ayuda nuevamente a cambio de alivio
no haber reconocimiento
y ese cambio ese cambio se está dando
no creo que haya una mejor manera de
representar esto que estoy tratando de
transmitir que lo que me tocó vivir
era el jueves a las 3 de la mañana
unas 38 horas después del terremoto
seguimos tratando de rescatar a la
persona o las personas
yo estaba en el centro de acopio
llenando un balde con chocolates y
dulces para repartir pilas
llegaron como a sesionar siete
trabajadores de la industria de la
construcción y su supervisor
ellos tendrían trabajando ahí 15 20
horas sin parar
sin ni siquiera tomar bien agua pues
para no tener que perder el tiempo en ir
a hacer pipí como como pensábamos los
demás
el supervisor acaba de llegar de la
cámara está todavía traía el almohadas o
marcado se los estaba tratando de llevar
bando nos decía vámonos mañana volvemos
bien temprano
vámonos me dijo el jefe que no los
expusiera demasiado
no uno de ellos no nos vamos a ir de
aquí hasta que saquemos a la chica quién
se queda
y uno a uno fueron levantando su brazo
cansado
dt tu si quieres leyeron al supervisor
realmente no tome fotos esos días pero
siete brazos arriba y un supervisor
adormilado es la única foto que me pesa
no haber tomado
[Aplausos]
[Música]